with kabul now under siege so are its
banks
people clamor to get their money out
security guards try to tell customers
not to worry but that's all most of them
can do ahmed ashraf says he has been
trying for three days to withdraw his
money he's from the northern city of
pulik umri that fell to the taliban last
week
the banks and all the provinces captured
by the taliban are not giving out any
money
among the panicked customers are many
government employees and police officers
some of whom haven't been paid for
months
this officer told us even the cash
machines are empty
everyone is very tense and everyone now
is looking at the banks to get their
money out and there's no money
prices for all basics from fuel to food
have been climbing steadily for months
as afghanistan has been sinking further
into conflict now they're skyrocketing
while increasing numbers of kabul
residents who have the means and a
passport have been looking for a way out
the cost of an airline seat has shot up
and that's if you can get one a one-way
ticket to istanbul has gone up by more
than five times to 2
400
while another airline doesn't give a
price on its website but asks you to
call for a quote
this is a city that has experienced
decades of trauma and it's now being
tested once more
rob mcbride al jazeera kabul